[Music]
I'm looking up waiting for a
color space and in Córdoba thanks to
the digital transformation program for
the employee hello my name is other
forms Let's see if Jiménez I'm 22 years old and
I'm fat I'm currently
using degrees in
genetic engineering and  electrical engineering or by the
university of huelva
hello my name is elisa de puertas de
iglesias and I am very happy to say that
I am a specialist in digital marketing
in which it was quite a challenge for more
resume that sent video of
overcoming job interviews that I
saw and tried  Even
signing up for job shuttles nothing
seemed to work was almost when I
was on the verge of despair
when I came across the
digital transformation course for employment
, however the profession I chose
required extra training to take
oppositions at that time the
job offers  there weren't many
so I wasn't very motivated to
continue training and it was  When I decided to
look for other alternatives, I
just determined the
digital transformation course offered
by the Unidad Industrial School,
this course helps me develop as
a teacher since I have acquired
skills and technical tools
on digitalization
at the same time that the
training was going on.  theory made me
discover myself as a more creative person,
talented by his
innovative vision, I had two
incredible mentors who helped me polish
certain doors that I needed,
the digital transformation course has allowed me to
join a
growing sector that is covered by a passion topic  and
above all, having a profession that
fits with my lifestyle thanks to
this course, as I have said, I could
develop as a professional in the line
of interests that acquiring this
course has been a great advantage over the
rest of my colleagues. Thank you very much,
thanks to  the help of the european social fund
i got the job  in
which I am right now and now
thanks to all the knowledge and my
experience I feel really
prepared to face any
challenge that occurs in my future
[Music]